Tessa Clarke: So it turns out
there’s a super simple solution
to the climate crisis.
Do you want to know what it is?
Audience: Yes.
TC: Good. I was hoping you would say that.
(Laughter)
All too often, the climate crisis
is illustrated with images of polar bears,
of wildfires and of floods,
while the headlines talk
about government negotiations
and net zero targets,
which makes it all feel
so far removed from us.
But there's something
we're not being told,
and it's that 65%
of all greenhouse gas emissions
are generated as a direct result
of household consumption.
So that's you.
And that's me.
What this means is we have enormous power
to solve the climate crisis.
And one of the simplest and most effective
ways in which we can do this
is to do something that humans have been
doing for thousands of years,
but then in modern life,
we've largely forgotten.
Put simply, it's to share more
and waste less.
Let's take food, for example.
Globally, one third
of all the food we produce each year
gets thrown away,
which is worth over a trillion US dollars.
And the environmental impact of this
is nothing short of devastating.
If it were to be a country,
food waste would be the third largest
source of greenhouse gas emissions
after the USA and China.
That's because a landmass
larger than China
is used every single year
to grow food that's never eaten.
That includes land
that has been deforested,
soil that has been degraded,
species that have been driven
to extinction.
It also includes all the packaging
and manufacturing,
refrigeration and distribution, too.
And when a third of that food
gets thrown away,
most of it ends up in landfill
where it creates methane,
which is over 25 times more deadly
than carbon dioxide.
The environmental impact
of food waste is so devastating
that Project Drawdown,
which is a collaborative piece of work
by several hundred of the world's
leading climate change scientists,
recently identified reducing food waste
as the number one most powerful lever
that humanity has
to solve the climate crisis.
Coming above electric cars,
above solar power
and above a plant-based diet.
To put all of this into a context
that's a little bit closer to home,
the carbon emissions
from just one kilogram of food waste.
Let's imagine your food waste caddy,
for example,
is equivalent to the carbon emissions
from landfilling how many
plastic bottles do you think?
One?
50? 100?
No.
25,000 plastic bottles.
So where does all this
food waste take place?
Surprisingly enough,
it's not at a retail store level.
In a country such as the UK,
which is typical
of much of the Western world,
half of all food waste
takes place in the home,
which means that we,
each and every one of us,
we are half of this enormous problem.
On the one hand, that's pretty depressing.
But if you flip it on its head,
it can be incredibly exciting, too,
because it means we don't have to wait
for governments or businesses.
We can be half the solution.
I grew up on a farm where food waste
was pretty much a crime
and where sharing was second nature,
from a glut of marrows
to hand-me-down clothes,
from a pony to a tractor.
But in modern life, we've largely
forgotten how to share.
That's because we all live
in our little boxes
stacked on top of one another,
beside one another.
We're no longer connected
to our local community.
And so we no longer have
anyone to share with.
That's why, along with my cofounder,
we created Olio.
Olio is an app that connects people
with their local community
so they can give away rather
than throw away their spare food.
How it works is really easy.
Let's imagine you're going away
for the weekend
or you've overcatered for a party.
Or perhaps your toddler's
favorite food yesterday
is their most hated food today.
(Laughs)
I think you've been there.
How it works is you just snap a photo
of your food and add it to the app.
People living nearby get an alert.
They can browse the listings,
request what they want
and pop round to pick it up.
Now you might be thinking,
who on earth would want my spare food?
But there is no shortage of demand.
The average listing is requested
in less than 25 minutes.
And it's in response to this demand
that we now also work with businesses
such as supermarkets, restaurants,
cafes and canteens.
This is powered
by 60,000 trained volunteers
who are members of our community,
who on their allotted time and day,
they pop out of their house
and they cross the street.
They go to the store
and they collect all of the unsold food.
They take it home.
They add it to the app.
Within minutes, people living nearby
are requesting it
and minutes later they're popping round
and picking it up,
taking that food from having been
considered waste in the store
to instead, on average, in just two hours
being fully redistributed
into multiple homes
in the local community.
This now enables businesses
to have zero food waste locations.
And our aim is that any business
anywhere in the world
can come onto the platform and organize
for their food to be redistributed
in their local community in minutes.
So that perfectly good food
is given away, not thrown away.
We launched in North London in 2015,
and since then, over 6 million people
from all around the world have joined us.
And together they have shared
66 million portions of food.
This has had an environmental impact
equivalent to taking
200 million car miles off the road
and has also saved
over 10 billion liters of water
because food production
is incredibly water-intensive.
But what's most exciting is we are doing
a tiny fraction of our full potential.
Just imagine the impact we can have
as we get millions and millions
more people sharing.
Now, whilst the environmental impact
of food sharing might seem quite obvious,
what's less obvious, but no less powerful
is the social impact of sharing.
Not only does it feel amazing to give away
something that you don't want
to someone who would like it,
sharing also creates connection
and strengthens community.
Over 40% of our users tell us that they
have made friends through the app
and 66% say that it has improved
their well-being.
And every day we hear
countless heartwarming stories,
in particular during COVID
and the cost of living crisis,
which reinforces the power
that doing something so simple
as sharing your spare can have.
The power of sharing
can be applied to so much more
than just solving
our food waste problem, though.
It can also help solve
our overconsumption problem more broadly,
which is best exemplified
by Earth Overshoot Day.
Earth Overshoot Day is the day in the year
in which humanity has used
all the resources
that the Earth can replenish in a year.
Back in 1971, Earth Overshoot Day
was the 25th of December.
What this means is that we used in a year
what the Earth could replenish in a year.
We were living in equilibrium
with the planet.
Fast-forward to today.
2022.
Earth Overshoot Day was the 28th of July.
What this means is that every single thing
that every single one of us,
almost 8 billion people,
are consuming after the 28th of July
is net-net depletive to the planet.
Another way of looking at it
is that collectively right now
we're living as if we have 1.75 planets,
which clearly we don't.
It appears that we are
shopping ourselves to extinction.
And this has to stop.
Where most people think
about playing their part
and living more sustainably,
the first thing that tends
to come to mind is recycling.
But given our relentless rate
of resource consumption,
we clearly cannot
recycle our way out of this mess.
What we need instead
is a brand new model of consumption.
One where all of our stuff
goes from being useless to useful.
From “who would want this?”
to “I would love that.”
From getting to giving,
from buying to borrowing,
from despair to hope.
Sharing instead of shopping
needs to become the default.
That's why we've extended
beyond just food sharing
and our community can now also give away
unwanted household items
such as toiletries, cleaning products,
kitchen appliances,
books, clothes and toys.
And they can also lend and borrow things
instead of buying brand new as well.
Because let's face it, we don't all need
our own air mattress or cat carrier
or disco ball or even,
dare I say it, popcorn maker.
(Laughter)
It gives me enormous hope to know
that we are part
of a broader global movement
of real sharing economy companies
that are springing up all over the world,
connecting communities
to share everything from clothing to cars.
And we're all united
by this simple belief.
That the status quo has to change.
And with businesses and governments
doing so criminally little
to solve the climate crisis,
we have set ourselves
an enormous ambition.
We want 1 billion people
to be consuming via Olio by 2030.
Because contrary to popular narrative,
what we do as individuals does count.
After all, it was billions
of small actions
that caused the climate crisis
in the first place.
And so surely, by the same logic,
billions of small actions
can help get us out of it.
Thank you.
(Applause)